wenn wir die Verlustquote an schweren
Systemen und schweren Fahrzeugen
anschauen dann haben wir nämlich bald
ein Jubiläum und ich denke das sagt mehr
als das ein langer Kommentar nämlich
10.000 10.000 schwere Waffensysteme und
schwere Fahrzeuge also inklusive Panzer
hat Russland bald verloren jedenfalls
nach der noch konservativen Zählung der
origex-liste und wenn Sie jetzt das mal
Herunterrechnen auf die Tage des
Kriegsverlaufs dann ist es eine
abnutzungsrate die Russland schlichtweg
nicht durchhalten kann das heißt das ist
eigentlich nur eine Frage der Zeit bis
in die Reserven ausgehen und was man
auch sehen muss ist die Medien
konzentrieren sich natürlich ganz extrem
auf bachmut es ist so ein bisschen
näheren Effekt aber man muss ja schauen
die russische Winteroffensive wenn man
sie so nennen will die fand ja nicht nur
im bachmut statt die fand eigentlich an
fünf verschiedenen konzentrierten Orten
statt also zum Beispiel auch im Raum
krimina
und auf die jewka in Marinka in vuleda
wo Russland alleine in zwei Tagen 130
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge verloren hat also
wenn wenn Sie den gesamten frontbogen
angucken und das sind nur etwa 120 km
der gesamtfront von 1200 dann ist das
einfach ein Desaster also das hat mit
militärischer Logik eigentlich nichts
mehr zu tun sondern das ist ein ein
massives hin Opfern von Reserven sowohl
was Material als auch Menschen angeht
für minimale Fortschritte sie haben das
Material angesprochen da gibt's bei uns
eine Frage im Stream bei Youtube von
User oder Userin Hip Hop geruhu er oder
sie fragt sich fragt mich bei all den
Bildern die man von russischen Equipment
meistens so sieht wo eigentlich Aldi
wirklich modernen Sachen sind
ja das frage ich mich auch häufig ich
habe ironischerweise 2014 als der Krieg
ja eigentlich losging mit mit der
Donders Invasion habe ich einen Artikel
geschrieben über den russischen armata
t-14 und habe gesagt ne also wir wissen
ja was da kommt und passt auf ne weil
der ist schon sehr mächtig und Kampf
fähig aber so wie sich bisher zeigt
scheint dir doch eher ein Phantom zu
sein also wir haben bisher diese
Exemplare gesehen auch Paraden aber im
Kampfraum bisher noch nicht das
modernste was wir bisher gesehen haben
ist der t9s eine Version die eigentlich
für den Export bestimmt ist und auch die
sind bereits abgeschossen worden genau
wie die T 80 DT 72 und so weiter also
man kann eigentlich sagen technologisch
gesehen eskaliert Russland nach unten äh
jetzt haben sie T64 mobilisiert und auch
T55 und es gibt bereits Sport im Netz
was kommt als nächstes T34 und danach
Pferde ähm also die die Frage ist völlig
berechtigt und ich denke es ist findet
hier wirklich eine große Verzauberung
der russischen armeestadt viele
Analysten ich übrigens auch haben sich
in der Vergangenheit einfach so ein
bisschen beeindrucken lassen von Zahlen
die die Russen gemeldet haben und
Systeme die sie vorgeführt haben auf
Paraden und und
gegenüber feindlichen
Nachrichtendiensten aber in Wirklichkeit
scheint da doch relativ wenig dahinter
zu stecken Sie das habe ich gelesen in
dem Interview in der NZZ sie sind sehr
optimistisch was den Ausgang des Krieges
für die Ukraine anbelangt sie nennen
sogar ein Zeitfenster an dem der Krieg
beendet sein soll sie haben also gesagt
in diesem Interview im Oktober wird die
Ukraine Russland besiegen wie kommen Sie
darauf
ja das hängt einfach mit der
abnutzungsrate der schweren Systeme
zusammen also in diesem Wind Interview
habe ich das am Beispiel der Panzer mal
vorgerechnet wie lange reicht die
Konsensschätzung über
russlandseinsatzfähige Panzer noch bis
sie endgültig alle weg sind und die
ähnliche Rechnung können sie für andere
schwere Fahrzeuge also für Arbeit
aufmachen ich entschuldige mich ein
bisschen für das Englisch wir fahren
jetzt gerade die die deutschen
Fachbegriffe nicht ein ähm aber wenn Sie
wenn Sie schauen mit welcher
unglaublichen rate diese Reserven
abschmelzen dann kommen sie sehr bald an
einen Punkt wo Russland einfach nicht
mehr in der Lage ist überhaupt noch
Operationen zu führen das heißt das
einzige was sie dann tun können ist sich
einzugraben das ist aber keine gute Idee
weil gegenüber steht ein anderes
Technologie denn die Ukraine geht jetzt
im Laufe des früheren Sommer eben über
von alter sowjetischer Technologie auf
westliche Technologie also insbesondere
auf westliche Kampfpanzer und
verlässliche infanteriefahrzeuge wie zum
Beispiel den Bradley oder den Marder und
das darf man auf keinen Fall
unterschätzen diesen Effekt bisher
kämpft in diesem Krieg sowjetmaterial
gegen sowjetmaterial aber das wird sich
fundamental ändern und
sobald die ukrainische
Frühjahrsoffensive losgeht also ich
rechne so etwa Mitte April damit da wird
man diesen technologie-effekt dann
deutlich sehen und das wird dann zu
einer noch größeren Verlustrate der
Russen führen wenn Sie das so ein
bisschen zusammen sich überlegen wozu
führt das eigentlich in der in der
gefechtsführung dann ist eigentlich gar
kein anderer Ausgang denkbar ich denke
Europa ist einfach im Moment so sehr
durchseucht von der russischen
Propaganda das viele ist schwierig
finden das zu glauben und deswegen sage
ich immer sie müssen das nicht glauben
es ist keine Frage des Glaubens sie
müssen einfach die Zahlen sich angucken
und die abnutzungsrate betrachten und
dann kommen sie eigentlich schon zu
belastbaren Schlussfolgerungen ich bin
übrigens wie immer von
wollen und und anderen Leuten scharf
angegriffen worden als ich das gesagt
habe aber ich möchte an der Stelle auch
sagen ich bin ja längst nicht der
einzige der das sagt Kellog sagt das
gleiche patrius sagt das gleiche Ben
Hodges auch also es ist nicht so dass
ich jetzt ein Exot wäre mit dieser
Meinung sondern es gibt durchaus ein
Konsens unter westlichen
militäranalysten oder zumindest unter
solchen die den Namen verdienen ich
möchte gern aber eine Frage von mir dazu
mit einer user-frage kombinieren weil
sie haben jetzt eben angesprochen also
anhand von Zahlen über Abnutzung kommen
Sie zu dieser Aussage also woher kommen
sie diese woher bekommen Sie die Zahlen
woher nehmen sie die und User ist am
Eckert möchte wissen wenn Herr Kolb von
Reserven spricht von welchem Zeitraum
ist da die Rede Monate Jahre und was
wird den Russen zuerst ausgehen Material
Munition oder Menschen
also zu der Konsensschätzung da können
Sie die schwedische verteidigungsagentur
fui heißt die mit Abkürzung anschauen da
gibt es 2019 gibt es eine wunderbare
Studie zur Kampfkraft der russischen sie
können ebenso das Institut für
stratetrix studies das iiss in London
angucken das bringt jedes Jahr der
militarlands raus und auch die kommen
auf eine etwa gleiche Konsensschätzung
also von ungefähr 2900 einsatzfähigen
System das ist für den Bestand und für
die Abnutzung nehme ich den orix-block
den kennen einige User vielleicht man
muss dazu sagen dieser Blog ist
wahrscheinlich noch konservativ weil er
eben nur das zählt an russischen
Verlusten was tatsächlich ein Bild oder
Video lokalisiert ist erzählt übrigens
auch die ukrainischen Verluste auch das
empfehle ich den Usern machen Sie
einfach mal direkten Vergleich oder
basteln sie sich selber ein kleines
Excel Charts und schauen Sie mal wie die
russischen Verluste sich verhalten im
Vergleich zu den ukrainischen und das
gibt ihnen ein recht gutes Bild welche
Mengen welche Massen an Material da
drauf gehen bei der russischen
Operationsführung zur letzten Frage ich
denke Russland werden als erstes die
schweren Systeme ausgehen also
insbesondere Kampfpanzer modernere Art
man muss aber auch sehen dass es ähm
Systeme gibt über die im Moment wenig
gesprochen wird insbesondere gegnerische
Radar Aufklärung gegen artiller
Systeme zur elektronischen Krieg Führung
die die Ukraine in den letzten Wochen
ebenfalls sehr erfolgreich
herausgenommen hat und auch das ähm
wirkt sich schädlich aus auf die
Möglichkeit der Russen überhaupt noch
offensiven
und wenn wir aber jetzt noch mal über
die Reserven sprechen also eine Reserve
die Russland haben könnte könnte ja auch
mehr Menschen sein es gibt also Berichte
darüber dass Russland 400.000 neue
Soldaten rekrutieren möchte das ist dann
auch nichts was sie von dieser Aussage
abbringen könnte weil 400.000 neue
Soldaten das könnte ja schon auch was
verändern oder ja das erinnert mich so
an diese propagandaerzählung die wir im
Februar hatten demnächst brechen 700.000
Mann durch die Dialog russischen Wälder
und Sümpfe und nehmen die Ukraine von
Norden allen hier also was sie zunächst
immer mal bedenken müssen ist russische
Ankündigungen und russische Realitäten
sind 12 völlig verschiedene Welten ich
weiß nicht warum das in Deutschland
immer so so wörtlich interpretiert wird
was die Russen sagen also sie müssen
wenn ein russischer Funktionär oder
Politiker sich äußert davon ausgehen
dass jedes Wort dass er sagt gelogen ist
und sofern es nicht gelogen ist ist es
mindestens um 200% übertrieben
wenn sie selbst an diese 400.000 jetzt
mal glauben möchten also nehmen wir mal
anders sei real auch dann dürfen sie
nicht Einsatzwert und einfach Anzahl
verwechseln also nur die Tatsache dass
sie irgendwelche armen Menschen in
diesem Fleischwolf da hineinwerfen an
der Front heißt es noch lange nicht dass
die Kampfkraft entfalten das haben sie
insbesondere in Volleder gesehen also
diese diese dilettantische Art wie die
Leute in den Fahrzeugen operieren und
die Fahrzeuge teilweise in offenen
Minenfelder hineinfahren das sagt Ihnen
vor allem eines das nämlich die
eigentliche professionelle russische
Armee die vor der Invasion bestanden hat
also die Kontakte die also sprich
sozusagen Soldaten auf Zeit die die gut
ausgebildet waren die auch gut bezahlt
waren dass die größtenteils ausgefallen
sind und durch schlechter oder gar nicht
ausgebildete mobics ersetzt worden sind
das heißt es kommt eigentlich nicht auf
die Anzahl der Menschen an bei der
Operationsführung es kommt auf ihren
Ausbildungsstand und ihre Kampfkraft an